in the early hours of this morning
following a call from neighbours
officers forced entry into a house here
in delaford road
inside the house they made a dreadful
discovery
of four people
who had been stabbed
despite the best efforts of officers and
paramedics
all four people were sadly pronounced
dead at the scene
i can confirm that the deceased were
three women
believed to be aged in their mid-60s 40s
and 30s
and one man believed to be aged in their
mid-60s
i want to offer my heartfelt condolences
to the family and friends of all those
concerned
this is a deeply shocking incident
and we will do everything we can to
provide support to everyone affected
at this difficult time
a man in his late 20s was arrested at
the address on suspicion of murder
and he is currently in custody
and at this early stage we're not
looking for any other person
we believe that all those involved may
have been known to each other
this is a terrible incident and i fully
understand the concern
communities will have
we are working closely with our partners
and local community groups to keep
everyone informed
your local officers will be in the area
to offer reassurance
so please speak to them they're there
for you to listen
and to act on your concerns
homicide detectives have launched an
investigation into these terrible events
so please assist them by avoiding
unhelpful speculation and allow them
time to uncover the evidence
such terrible events are rare
but this will not diminish the shock
that we felt across london and beyond
and i can assure you this investigation
will be thorough to ensure justice for
the victims and their families and the
community
anyone who has information in relation
to this should contact the police